y
[Música]
xiomara castro asumido como primera
presidenta en la historia de honduras
juramento a los integrantes de su
gabinete y reiteró su compromiso de
luchar contra el narcotráfico y el
crimen organizado a la posición asistió
la vicepresidenta de eeuu cámaras aves
el consejo nacional electoral de
venezuela declaró improcedente del
proceso con el que varios movimientos
buscaban revocar el mandato del
presidente nicolás maduro los impulsores
de la iniciativa pedirán la nulidad de
la recolección de firmas después de que
no se alcanzaran las necesarias para
avanzar en el referéndum
eeuu reiteró su voluntad de responder
contundentemente a rusia si decide
invadir ucrania y volverá a llevar el
tema del consejo de seguridad de
naciones unidas esto después de que el
kremlin resumiera con poco optimismo las
respuestas de la casablanca y la otan
sobre sus exigencias de seguridad
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en honduras
xiomara castró se convirtió en la
primera presidenta en la historia de esa
nación centroamericana la funcionaria
juramento a su gabinete y se comprometió
a refundar honduras luchando contra el
narcotráfico y el crimen organizado la
presidenta recibe el país con un índice
de pobreza del 70 por ciento en medio de
denuncias de corrupción en el anterior
gobierno y falta de transparencia de las
instituciones además de la inestabilidad
política generada en los últimos días
luego de que se posesionarán en
simultáneo dos juntas directivas del
parlamento el estado de honduras
ha sido hundido estos últimos 12 años
y lo recibo en bancarrota
el país
debe de saber
qué hicieron con el dinero y dónde están
los 20 millones de dólares
que sacaron en préstamos mi gobierno
no continuará a la vorágine de saqueo
que ha condenado a las generaciones de
jóvenes
a pagar la deuda que contrajeron a sus
espaldas en venezuela- del consejo
nacional electoral declaró improcedente
del proceso de revocatoria del mandato
del presidente nicolas maduro luego de
que sólo se recolectarán 42 mil 421
firmas de las 42 millones necesarias de
igual forma informó que ya no se
aprobaran más solicitudes para tramitar
otra revocatoria pues la constitución
estipula un solo proceso por mandato uno
de los movimientos promotores del
revocatorio anunció que solicitará la
nulidad del proceso de recolección de
firmas
el consejo nacional electoral
declara
improcedente la solicitud del referéndum
revocatorio
al mandato del presidente
igualmente el consejo nacional electoral
declara
sin lugar
una nueva solicitud de referéndum
revocatorio contra el mandato del
presidente de la república nicolás
maduro moro en argentina cientos de
personas salieron a las calles para
exigirle al gobierno que omita el pago
del próximo vencimiento de la deuda por
44 mil millones de dólares que tiene con
el fondo monetario internacional desde
2018 la administración de alberto
fernández se enfrenta al pago este
viernes de 730 millones de dólares y
otros 365 millones de dólares el martes
el ejecutivo lleva meses de
negociaciones con el organismo hasta el
momento infructuosas para reestructurar
la millonaria obligación
al menos 5 millones de personas cayeron
en la pobreza extrema en américa latina'
en 2021 esa es la conclusión del más
reciente informe de la comisión
económica para américa latina y el
caribe cepal que indica que durante el
segundo año de pandemia alrededor de 86
millones de latinoamericanos sufrieron
la extrema pobreza la mayor cifra en 27
años el organismo señaló que la
recuperación económica de 2021 no fue
suficiente para mitigar los profundos
efectos sociales y laborales de la
crisis sanitaria
la pandemia ocasionó una salida
contundente sobre todo de las mujeres
del mercado laboral creo que las mujeres
y los jóvenes como veremos más adelante
han sufrido las consecuencias más duras
porque una de dos o han tenido o no han
encontrado empleo o las mujeres que han
tenido una salida contundente del
mercado laboral o bien han entrado a
precariedad laboral con pérdida de
ingresos aumento en la sobrecarga del
trabajo en cuidados en otras noticias
los presidentes de eeuu y ucrania
hablaron telefónicamente este jueves yo
by the end reiteró a su homólogo
volodymyr selenski su voluntad de
responder con contundencia si rusia
invade a ucrania
washington también convocó una reunión
del consejo de seguridad de naciones
unidas el próximo lunes para tratar la
crisis esto ocurre después de que rusia
considerara que sus principales
peticiones en materia de seguridad
fueron ignoradas tanto por la unión
americana como por la otan
las exigencias de moscú no han sido
escuchadas por washington y sus aliados
ese fue el mensaje enviado por el jefe
de la diplomacia rusa también
contiene una reacción que nos permite
esperar que se inició un diálogo serio
pero sobre las cuestiones secundarias en
cuanto a la cuestión principal no hay
ninguna reacción positiva en el
documento la cuestión principal es
nuestro claro mensaje de que
consideramos inaceptable una mayor
expansión de la otan hacia el este y el
despliegue de armas que pueden amenazar
a la federación rusa de georgia no tan
vasto que voy ayer eeuu y la otan
rechazaron como era de esperarse la
principal demanda rusa el fin de la
política de ampliación de la alianza
atlántica una decisión bien recibida por
kiev en otras palabras moscú quiere
evitar a toda costa que su vecino se
convierta en miembro del bloque algún
día representantes rusos y ucranianos se
reunieron el miércoles en parís unos
debates con la mediación de francia y
alemania- ambas partes se comprometieron
de nuevo a respetar el alto al fuego en
la región del donbass pero no hubo otra
clase de progreso se espera otro
encuentro en febrero si la buena noticia
es que los consejeros han acordado o
reunirse en berlín dentro de 15 días lo
que significa que al menos durante las
próximas dos semanas es probable que
rusia se mantenga en la vía diplomática
extra no preocupado por una posible
escalada militar el gobierno de dubai
then ha instado a sus ciudadanos a
considerar salir de ucrania ahora mismo
y ha advertido que el oleoducto norte
windows entre alemania y rusia no
avanzará de haber una invasión en
paralelo un debate entre manuel marco y
vladimir putin está previsto para este
viernes cuando se cumplen 77 años de la
liberación del campo de concentración de
auschwitz birkenau y en el día
internacional de conmemoración en
memoria de las víctimas del holocausto
el presidente francés emmanuel mckeown
instó a francia a no repetir los errores
del pasado el discurso del mandatario se
produjo mientras la alemana margot
freedland a superviviente del holocausto
advirtió ante el parlamento europeo que
el antisemitismo es un peligro para el
mundo
no olvidar nunca a las víctimas del
holocausto ni repetir las atrocidades
del pasado este fue el mensaje que lanzó
el presidente francés emmanuel mack con
este jueves e internacional de la
memoria del holocausto en un tuit mccrum
se comprometió a no ceder nunca ante
quienes intentando reescribir la
historia esto siguió a un compromiso el
jueves por la noche en un evento
organizado por el congreso judío europeo
como la lucha que compartimos es una
lucha esencial para la civilización
europea y para francia como nación y
como república esta lucha por desgracia
se ha convertido en una realidad una vez
más ya que se han levantado de nuevo
vientos adversos y se han instalado
ciertas ideas el aniversario de la
liberación de auschwitz birkenau el
mayor campo de exterminio nazi por parte
del ejército rojo en 1945 es la fecha
elegida por la unión europea para el día
internacional del recuerdo del
holocausto el jueves ante el parlamento
europeo en bruselas
la alemana mcguffin lander superviviente
del holocausto subrayó la importancia de
mostrar la humanidad
yo mismo he tenido la experiencia de
cómo la gente ha negado a otras personas
esa humanidad esto no debe volver a
ocurrir por eso ahora debemos estar
atentos y no mirar hacia otro lado como
hicimos entonces el odio el racismo y el
antisemitismo deben ser la última
palabra de la historia he tenido que ver
con mis propios ojos y experiencia a
dónde conduce esto pues yo dije en 2022
se cumplen 77 años de la liberación del
campo y lander advirtió que el
antisemitismo está aumentando mientras
que el presidente de la comisión europea
prometió no cerrar los ojos a la
historia es todo por el momento a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía quédense
con nosotros que volvemos en breve a
quien france24
[Música]